alfonso ribeiro's been in many many
television ventures and many many
ventures
catch-21 is something that my kids
cannot stop watching
and i love it too and then mark sanchez
is going to join us as he was the latest
unmasked individual on the mass singer
my kids can't get enough of that
and uh you know uh clearly me as well uh
since i'm now
four months running into this sign being
on my desk best dad ever
thank you and joining us right now here
on the show as promised
enjoyed the last time he was on which
makes me even more excited to welcome
him back to the program on behalf of
america's funniest home videos which is
sunday at 7 00 p.m eastern on abc
returning this sunday for its 31st
season
and his sixth is host alfonso ribeiro
how are you sir
i'm rich how are you buddy good to see
you again
talk to you again hear your voice i feel
like you are here how are you how's life
everything yeah it really has been uh
you know an
interesting year so far obviously for
all of us yes um
but uh my family and i we decided that
we were going to buy an rv
and we've been rving since june um all
around the country
um we feel like it's the greatest way
to social distance while still having
somewhat of a social life
where you can actually go and and you
know talk to your camping neighbor
that's you know 20 yards away from you
but still just
shout over to them and enjoy um a
campfire so
uh it's uh it's been an interesting
summer but
you know we're we're making the most of
it it's a beautiful country we have sir
so where have you where have you been
what have you seen
well uh literally i've driven 14 000
miles since
june so we've seen everything
the only the only area we didn't go into
was the northeast
this year because obviously in uh you
know may and june
uh no one was trying to go into the the
northeast
right we've gone from you know la all
the way
to florida to washington state
idaho arkansas
texas lake powell we've seen
almost everything uh we you know we
believe that uh
for our family uh the idea of reading
about something in a book is great yes
but how much better is it to actually go
and actually experience it so that's
what we're doing we're going and
experiencing
as much as we can during during this
pandemic damn so okay let's
um i'm i'm not done with this line yet
this is fascinating to me
um so how many children have you brought
with you how many are on this
well uh we started out with all four my
my now 18 year old
decided of course as a you know teenager
they're like i need to go back to my
friends
right so she went back but i've got the
three little ones i've got
my six turning seven my five-year-old
and my one-year-old uh
all all rolling with me 14
000 miles that's a yeah i imagine
there's a lot of ipad chargers
a lot a lot of um a lot of data that
that's a big thing when you really start
to get down to
what you need in an rv it's called data
and now with
everybody you know streaming everything
everywhere
yes the the companies don't sell you a
lot of data anymore that whole unlimited
plan
for data yeah that doesn't exist you
can't find it anywhere so
um yeah i've been buying a lot of data
my gosh and then data's been driving too
so for did uh
can you uh parallel park one of those
beasts now i mean like
absolutely no i i've pulled in i i've
actually
i i have to say i'm gonna toot my own
horn for one second but
there were several places that i've gone
into where
the neighbors all would come out to
watch me pull in
yes and i've gotten a round of applause
at least once or twice
it's been pretty good you know they were
like okay okay you did that in one shot
okay congrats
you you know what you're doing um it's
uh
it's amazing how you can learn stuff
from
youtube oh yeah so you go i went online
and i
i watched a bunch of this because you
have to actually get a license
to drive um an rv this size i have a
41 footer and the
the thing is it's real simple once you
understand it
the rear tires are the pivot points
okay so everything in front of the rear
tire
when you turn goes right and you turn
right
everything behind the rear tire goes
left
and once you understand that then you
understand that you've got to drive the
rv
into the intersection to allow the rear
tire to get
to the curb right to then start making
the turn because if not
you're going to hit that light pole yeah
i'm going to hit the light pole
i'm going to be honest with you
i don't know that's that is amazing man
so i imagine your golf game has suffered
miserably
you know what's weird is it hasn't
when you're scratching yeah well like
you know normally it's like i'm a three
day a week
every week you know and i take a break i
don't know what i'm doing but
um for some reason i've made a swing
adjustment that my coach worked with me
on
um almost a year ago and now when i
don't play for a while
the technique comes back it's a more
sustainable swing
so um i just played at the pure first p
for the pga tour champions up at pebble
beach yes
i shot 33 on my back nine on saturday
come
in stop come on come on come on come on
and and yeah and and the teaser set up
for the champions league is what you're
saying
yeah i didn't play all the way back
because they have us up at the at an
amateur tee box but it's
it's not like we're 30 40 yards in front
of them
typically we're you know 10 15 yards in
front of them so it's it's still
you know it was it was something that
i'm very proud of to shoot 33 on my on
my uh
on my back nine so uh
i do have to ask what the front nine was
alfonso i'm sorry i got to ask what the
front nine was
listen listen listen why we gotta why we
don't need to go
come on even if it starts with a four
even if it starts with a four-year-old
it was a 41-33 i i i figured some things
out
chris brockman when i ever say to you
that i'm embarrassed sheepishly telling
you about my 74
yeah at pebble beach please i'm going to
punch you in the face
michael thomas you rich oh my god
that's impress 14 000 miles at the wheel
of a 41 foot rv
that is you are amazing yeah i'll fonts
not getting a lot of rounds in right now
but um but i did buy a simulator
and every time i'm at home i use it so
it's it's uh
it's it's i you know me you you know me
rich i love my golf
i'm i'm so into it um you know but
but i felt like during this time it's
been really nice to be able to
you know put my one-year-old down for
naps and
and spend such quality time with the
kids that
normally i would never get this
opportunity to do that so
um you know trying to look at this thing
half full
alfonso ribeiro here on the rich eisen
show and uh i assume it has not affected
your crossover dribble uh with that
chris paul commercial i saw every two
seconds during the nba playoffs
i mean look my hook shot needs some work
uh
of those one of those uh commercials
uh but you know the funny part with the
with the the state farm ads
has been when i get people who call me
and they're like and they'll say on
instagram or whatever and they'll like
you know dude
your makeup artist stinks like the back
of your head look all jacked up i'm like
that was on purpose we did that
it's the second level of comedy okay the
character
did a bad version of doing his own
head don't worry about it it's beyond
you guys
hey you're in a commercial with chris
paul everyone should just back off you
win
they lose what are we talking about
pretty pretty cool and he's a great dude
he was awesome to work with
uh fun to play around with and and and
you know it was it was kind of crazy
when that when they came to me with that
because the idea of like
i've been watching these state farm ads
you know since the beginning
loving all of them and now to like be in
a campaign
and and they actually turned out really
funny in my opinion so
i i was happy with the work that we did
and um
it was a pleasure doing it hope
hopefully they call me again
and do round two of the of the ads we
have seen those those that have happened
before alfonso ribeiro here on the rich
eisen show
i i imagine uh with everyone
you know hopefully quarantining in in
numbers
that the number of opportunities for
someone to shoot a home video
that is hilarious and worthy of being
submitted to your program that you you
have a record number
of videos from which to sift through uh
would that be a proper assumption
that would be uh an understatement
actually
they've gotten up to five times um
the amount of videos that we normally
would get
uh every every month uh people have
their phone on them they don't have a
lot of stuff they can go do
there are a lot of people who are out
there you know making videos
so uh we've had um an incredible amount
great videos we've already shot uh eight
episodes so far
and um what we're doing very differently
this year
obviously with no audiences right
um we're using the same technology
that the nba has used to zoom in an
audience
okay so we have a zoomed in audience
watching every one of our shows so the
feeling and the energy is exactly the
same
um it's been really really interesting
to do it on set
while they're not there i can't talk to
them in person right there but they're
still
laughing at the jokes and laughing at
the little bit that we do
and and and the energy's there and i get
to see them laugh and smile and so
it's uh i'm excited to see and i've seen
that the first episode that airs
this sunday on abc and um
i think people are going to feel like
the the show is very much the same show
so we can zoom in we can be like the
the people in the uh in the stands and
the nba finals and stuff like that we
can just be what i really want them to
do
i actually i'm making them i'm going to
make a suggestion now that you've kind
of
clicked it into my head yes i think we
should do a you know a celebrity
who can spot the celebrity in our zoomed
in audience right
um on every episode that we shoot from
here on out we need to get one celebrity
just to kind of
zoom in to our show okay alfonso
look i just try to i just want to make
you better than how i found you
that's that's what i do as a host and
yet honestly like
uh you're on my tvs every two seconds my
kids are constantly watching game show
network i'm watching
old versions of catch 21 i'm watching
the most recent versions of it
and then you're popping up on the
commercials during the nba playoffs
you know i mean a lot of fun it's a lot
of fun um you know the the uh
the covet obviously has affected us from
not being able to
to do the um to do the game show yet to
come back and do
another season of the game show yes
because we have an audience we actually
have to have um everything kind of
done the right way of course and um so
we're waiting for us to be allowed to
have an audience and we'll
we'll go ahead and shoot another season
of catch 21. looking forward to that
alfonso uh great chatting with you um
i'm glad that uh everything is well with
you
and uh i always appreciate us uh
chitchat and thanks for the call
absolutely thanks richard great take
care right back at you hit him straight
i don't need to tell you but clearly
all right take it easy alfonso ribeiro i
shot a 33.
oh twist my arm i shot a 41 on the front
you could do the math that's 74. if i
shoot a 74. i'm getting
tattooed gigantic like eight like three
feet on my back i i shot a 74.
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here